denis villeneuve sci-fi drama rival hit
theaters in 2016 and earned rave reviews
from critics thanks to Amy Adams
brilliant performance bill knobs
excellent direction and amateur focused
take on the alien invasion genre but
that doesn't mean it isn't confusing in
fact a rivals focus on linguistics and
space-time theory is tough to untangle
it only seems to get more complex the
deeper you dive into it we've got you
covered if you're ready to dig deep and
don't mind spoilers here's everything
you need to know about arrivals
confusing ending the sapir-whorf
hypothesis if you want to understand
this complex film first you need to wrap
your head around the linguistic theory
at the center of it which holds that our
perception of reality is either altered
or determined by the language we speak
an example of the hypothesis in action
the Hungarian word for Raccoon an animal
that doesn't exist in Central Europe
outside of television in zoos is moso
medved which literally translates to
washing bare the idea is that Hungarians
colorful term for raccoons also affects
their perception of the creature itself
so that they can see and understand it
differently than those of us are just
calling a [ __ ] a raccoon or a trash
panda rewiring Louise's brain so the
sapir-whorf hypothesis states that our
realities determined by our language in
arrival that argument is pushed to its
outer limits doctor lees bangs is the
one who first begins to truly learn and
comprehend the hepta pods strange
nonlinear mode of communication
thus she's also the first to perceive
reality space and time the same way the
aliens do the total overhauled Louise's
reality begins shortly after she teaches
the hepta pods her and ian's names while
dissecting some printouts of the alien
language she has this vision of her
daughter playing with a caterpillar in a
field a moment easily dismissed as a
random memory of the daughter she lost
but these flashbacks intensify and
appear more frequently as she learns
more of the hepta pods language leaving
two a bombshell moment in which what
seem like memories are now revealed to
be visions of Louise's future weapon
opens time dr. banks job is to find out
why the hepta pods came to earth leading
to a global international crisis when
the hepta pods say that they're here to
quote give weapon what what Louise
realizes is that the aliens don't really
mean weapon they mean tool and the tool
they intend to give humanity is their
language which will come in handy three
thousand years from now when the
two pods face extinction and neap
humanities help since people who speak
have to pod experienced time in
nonlinear form they're capable of
drawing on experiences from anywhere
within their own existence to make
choices and change events as how Louise
is able to flash-forward eighteen months
to the gala where she encounters Chinese
general Shang who tells her what she
said to him to stop him from starting a
war of the worlds' in the present and
since Shang has learned to speak haft
upon himself in those intervening months
he also perceives time not linearly so
he knows that what he tells Louise and
his timeline will be useful to her past
self confused let rust Cole help you out
we see our space town with a flattened
pepti pod time is like that beer can a
flat circle and on a flat circle cause
and effect can happen in any direction
what Louise says to Shang leads him to
speak to her at the gala
but what Shang says to Louise at the
gala also leads her to say what she said
that makes perfect sense as long as you
accept one more hypothesis everything is
predetermined
needless to say Louise returns from her
mental flash-forward to make the phone
call that saves the world and everyone
lives happily or tragically ever after
but what if she simply chose not to
that's the bad news
she can't choose in order for that
future conversation at the gala to
happen and it does Louise has to follow
through on the phone call this is the
other big difference between linear and
nonlinear time in linear time you can
make choices that alter the shape of
your future you might be able to move in
only one direction but every choice you
make represents a fork in the road in
nonlinear time life is a circular track
on which you can travel either backward
or forwards but there's no branching off
the existence of freewill is
fundamentally incompatible with a
nonlinear experience of time which is
also the heart of a rival speaking hepta
pod gives Louise the ability to see the
future but shatters her illusions of
ever being able to change it thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]